right the u.s supreme court has not
released its decision in this hotly
anticipated abortion case that has not
stopped the left from threatening
violence if they don't get their
preferred outcome and today when nancy
pelosi was actually asked directly
whether democrats and their rhetoric is
to blame for the threats and the
assassination plot for example against
justice kavanaugh she dodged the
question spewed more abortion alarmism
what kind of answer is this take a look
as far as the abortion case is concerned
there has been a number of attacks on
uh on on churches on crisis pregnancy
centers republicans are
going after democrats for not saying
anything and they're saying that that
your rhetoric is contributing to these
attacks on these crisis well let me just
say this
a woman has a right to choose to live up
to her responsibility it's up to her
her
doctor her family her husband her her
significant other and her god
uh this talk of politicizing all of this
i think
is something uniquely american and not
right
hey nancy is it hard to condemn the
rhetoric is it hard to condemn the
harassment the intimidation not really
by the way we still haven't heard a
single word from joe biden about the
attempted assassination of a sitting
supreme court justice now keep in mind
these are the same democrats that were
silent about the 574 riots in the summer
of 2020 they were either quiet or the
same ones that were out there saying oh
no they're mostly peaceful they're only
obsessing over one riot that we saw on
january 6. the same ones they refused to
ask why the president authorized the
national guard to be deployed up to 20
000 troops and nancy pelosi chuck
schumer sergeant of arms and by the way
the capitol police chief they
never were given an answer although
muriel bowser put it in writing by the
way even when they were warned that
things would get out of hand they did
nothing hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else